Once upon a time, a very long time ago
, people all of the world suddenly became panicking
b
[music]
Until then, what everyone had made was broken, but one
day 3700 years later, on
the stage of an empty knight, Seb
I did a lot of experiments with my favorite price, and
finally made a machine to recover from petrification
.  In
order to fight ska, Senku made it in the back,
even if there was some science to discuss. Suica and
other children's teams also helped make mobile phones
.
]
Yes
, I'm exhausted from the battle I'm
going to listen to my sweat
ana
Hmmm, what's wrong with Suika-chan?
I want to be able to talk to everyone,
but I
haven't gone to battle, so there
are a lot of things I don't know.
It's a big master's art
So, Sengen-chan, please talk about it.
That kind of talk is 10 billion percent game,
but it's your job,
but I don't
have a clue about
science.  Hey
Stone Otsu started from capturing Tsukasa-chan, the empire's watchman,
Homura-chan
.
That's right, we brought it in while we were catching Homura-chan, but it's hard on Doi day. What do you think
the stupid light box that you worked so hard to make is
for?
Modern warfare  The strongest weapon is
information communication It's
good until the time is
red, so it's not unnatural to talk with the four companies
teetai
tan
tan It's
true that my wife made a noise around here, but
Homura-chan, who is as fast as Kohaku-chan, is
too loud to hear  Kyo-chan and Kasukasa-
chan's qualifications are a team and troublesome, are
n't they?
I'm glad I managed to open a cell phone hotline with Taiji-chan and
the others,
but Kurom-chan
got caught.  It's the place where
I'm at,
Sugiko,
now is
the time for me, so I
can't find a child actor
.  A big tengu
I guess I'm standing here
[music]
This is the weakness of the monthly chrome, is
n't it
?  From
here on out, Taiki-chan and the others will do their best
Tsukasa-chan made the members of the empire
into her comrades
, right?
Leave it to me, what are you talking about? It's nothing, I'm going with
Nikki-chan and I'm Tono.
The strategy is to not let
Suika-chan, who is pure and straightforward, run wild
First of all, I'll deliver the phone to Taiki-chan and the others
Secretly listen to the commander
and play Lillian-chan's song to deceive The world is
n't destroyed oh
[music]
Boo Boo  It's erotic, isn't
it soaked in water? It's the start of a decisive battle with the empire, is
n't
it?  Everyone seems to have instinctively understood,
right
now I told Kabako that my business opportunity was completely destroyed.
Yes,
we believe in chemical
shakes
[music]
Nyan tax
sulfuric acid, but it's
lycerin registered at the old Roy Station
It's like dynamite
car
Well, I might have understood it from an election perspective,
but it's not like it's settled.
I was crazy
What is the price for what are you
living for?
is a sluggish sister resurrected
doggy The card that demands a truce instead is a truce Reasons to believe that [ __ ]
My family of Cotebutter I
can't lie without my
mother Sister Tari
[music]
No,
enough,
enough
So, Stone Otsu got a lucky offer,
so it was a love battle.
No, everyone's combined strength
led to the victory of the Kingdom of Science.
Hey,
cold sleep huh
, I've only heard it in sci-fi spaceships
[music] There
's only one way to save the slump
Tsukasa
petrify
me charvel mpe
r 2
ah ah ah
me
[music
] If that happens, I'm ready to depart  Let's start with the
dots, ame
goo
Yes, everyone's
attention
Yamazen A mystery that suddenly fell 700 years ago
All human beings are petrifying rays But we will use science
to find out the current state of petrification and get that light Our
aim is the source of the light, the
earth  That's right, we're all on the back side, so
we're all
going to
make 4
me
[music]
Sakura Aijutsu
or were you here?
[music] The
chalk is invalid
It's the skies, but it's
a gold ski that's used in the
battle skies.
It's going to
be
over I'm having too much fun This is too much fun
It's funny that I've seen it already-I can't see a lot of it anymore
The blood of science users is making a fuss This is a big adventure in the world
Hey, even
I might get a little excited if it's this big
[music] Get on
the ship 2
I don't want to go  Ah,
first of all, quickly create a knot of system chemistry
Stone World It's the start of the Great Voyage Age
Each of
these is
[music]